hi my name is Dan Pena and I'm thanking
every Carmichael for the opportunities
giving me for this cameo if you will
focus that's it focus but without money
you can't save up thing don't you
understand we all know nobody can have
ten times our IQ well then why the hell
do people make ten times more than we do
a thousand times more than we do
why how many times do I have to say you
had the script
hello Lanisha my name is Evan Carmichael
my one were to believe it I believe that
entrepreneurs will solve all of the
world's major problems so the health of
your journey today we're going to learn
from author and business coach Dan Pina
and my face on his top 10 to success all
you to number six is my personal
favorite and I'd love to know which ones
you guys like to bet and as always as
you're watching teach you something
that's really resonates with you please
leave it in the comments below so folks
around other people can be inspired my
printer prize as well and also when you
write it down as much more likely to
stick for yourself system enjoy
Warren Buffett and Bill Gates
simultaneously said one word focus
that's it
focus and in many years that I was a
hundred percent focus and I created a
lot a lot of wealth for myself I only
thought about one thing and that was it
and I'm not I'm not saying that it's
easy because if it were easy they'd be
like a qlae shop on every corner like
Starbucks my market is seven hundred
thousand people out of seven billion if
you want to be me
seven hundred thousand out of seven
billion I don't know what fraction that
is but it's not a very big one that's it
there's seven hundred thousand people on
the planet that can commit to the focus
the laser beam focus of the gates
Trump's Ellison's etc if you if you want
to if you want to create generational
wealth generational wealth is welted you
make in twenty to twenty-five years
because depending on who where you
google it a generation age of twenty or
twenty-five years we do that and I've
taught and I did it myself how to do it
in four to seven years and the in
virtually throwing everything that
you've learned or read out the window
but it's focused and not that many
people can stay focused
in fact that's an understatement that
gross understand hardly anybody can stay
focused unless we build the right
foundation I mean the house will be
woolly and it will be you know you got
it we got to build the right foundation
and for the most part most people in
this room and most people listen on
YouTube have to come to the realization
as sad as it is ish you have pissed you
have urinated heretofore up until this
morning your entire life down a people
very simple that's it if you want to
create massive wealth if you just want
to be a happy slappy housewife from
Dundee or happy slappy bimbo from
Toronto or happy slappy guy who goes to
the Little League game and base to
Arizona
then that's okay but if you want to
create some money and money's not
everything but if you don't want to
think money can buy happiness you don't
know where to shop you can get money and
then go save the world
and then get money and save the forest
in Brazil you make money and go save
global warming which I don't believe in
because I mean and say that the pimp
kids in buy a four no elections but
without money you can't save up thing
don't you understand
don't do it it's on YouTube understand
that and tell you making shekels until
you make some coin you can't help
anybody
because if love got the job done you
wouldn't all be up we have two bank
accounts like I said earlier a financial
bank account and emotional bank account
and where we all fail myself included is
emotionally I get afraid you know but
it's not what happens to you in life
it's how you react to what happens to
you in life I just push through I'm so
used to success now you know not blowing
smoke up my owner I'm so used to it now
it's my fact pattern I mean it's mine
nobody's interested in the failures I've
had last year I had tried 22 different
things that failed when I tried to there
were big successes so nobody's
interested in the well I think we'll try
this and it didn't work I think I tried
this and it didn't work the system that
I've seen that works which is very much
contrary to all the other success guys
which I don't consider myself is the
mentorship or if somebody mentors you
this so define somebody it is where you
want to be and is accomplished all this
either man or woman and then you find
them
and you come to them with your dream and
your passion and in assuming the
chemistry's right and it's not always
right the rest is history
it's like the Tyson Gus D'Amato deal you
know yeah okay
Tyson by accident the greatest respect
Mike found that guy when he was 13 14
years old when he was you know doing all
kind of ugly things not dissimilar to
myself but the same age and and Gus
mentored him and took him in then as
that in you know Mike will admit I guess
I don't know I've never talked to him
about you know when when gusts died and
all that all that stuff happened he made
some poor to some very poor decisions so
you got to find that person and you
don't just you know you're not just
going to find them you know walking down
the street on the high street I mean you
have to make a concerted effort to find
somebody that that you you look up to
and normally that person is several
years older than you but they're
successful in what you want to do if you
had to keep track of seven days a week
24 hours a day what you do you would be
shocked astounded overwhelmed or as they
say in Britain gobsmacked how much time
you waste and I'm a can keep track of
every minute of the day every minute of
the day and it's not easy it's not easy
and when you find it out the I have
people that have come to the seminar
it's been 20 hours a day walking in the
fresh air in meditating 20 hours a week
excuse me none day 20 hours a week and
you don't get anything done and they
don't feel relaxed what takes you off
what like what really sets you off right
now you mean irritates me irritates you
pisses you off their man's greatest
burden is unfulfilled potential man's
greatest burden is unfulfilled potential
and I say when I look at the audiences
and I know that maybe only 1%
are going to achieve their potential not
fully put I've still haven't fulfilled
my potential but unfulfilled potential
was man's greatest burden and it breaks
my heart because I know what you kids
are capable of I know I've had kids with
AD IQ to 180 IQ that I mentored that
have that have done big big deals
actually the ad IQ did better than the
hunter Navy IQ okay and I know what
they're capable of and I know how ten
million or 100 million or whatever the
number is changes lives and the and then
all of a sudden you know you believe
that you can walk on water you believe
that you can take a loaf of bread and
feed however mean he was supposed to
have fed and make water into wine and
when you believe it see the true test of
a leader is when you've trained other
people to be leaders it's in you kids
I mean you can do it if you want it bad
enough and you stay focused and you're
willing to maintain that commitment my
dad was a workaholic he was a cop but he
was a workaholic when he retired from
the LAPD after 28 years he had 700 plus
days they wrote him a check for he never
took a day off 728 years he never took a
day off it was always at work and the so
I saw that and I said you know and
although then he went on he went to the
CIA and he became a college professor
but I saw him work hard and the and I
aspired to follow my day and my dad's
footsteps it as far as that was
concerned I turned 16 which is when you
can get a permit to work legally and I
got a job as a box-boy which they don't
have anymore where you put groceries in
the ladies bags and you come out to the
car the first month that I worked was
August 1961 when I turned 16 so my
birthday's the 10th so I worked 20 days
21 days my page
I just happened to look it up was 241
bucks so I worked about 240 hours in 20
days you you got a headache you don't
want to work I'll take your shift you
want to go to to the beach I'll take
your shift okay
so my first month that I first 20 day to
work I was averaging 10 12 hours a day
when I'm 16 years old I realized as a
LAN musk we shouldn't li said if you
work 80 hours a week and another guy
works 20 40 hours a week unless you're
something's wrong with you you're going
to get twice as much done I I discovered
that prayer is great contemplation is
great but if you don't take action
action action all the rest is wasted and
what the kids today have trouble with
they Cano reading a book to take an
action
all in all nothing you shouldn't read
because I've read the classics I've read
Shakespeare and all that stuff but it's
not taking action taking action is
pulling the trigger going out and making
something happen and even if you fail
I'm 15 pounds overweight my doctor said
and he said you know if you wanted to be
in perfect health which everything else
is perfect my health I'm well you should
lose 15 pounds and I said I'd have to
give up three or four martinis and a
bottle of wine every night I'm not
willing to do that it's I know what it
takes and I know what I have to do I
used to run marathons on the Boston
Marathon and I know what it took the
Train and I'm not you know I don't run
like that anymore I scare master but I
mean I we all know how to lose weight we
all know how to get physically fit we
all know how to build our businesses I
can go to the Yellow Pages today and
pick out any businesses in this room and
I can find somebody that's beating your
brains out I don't care what you do and
as some of you have heard me say but I'm
going to say it again because it's
important for this example again we're
all have 100 IQ for some of you I'm
giving you some for some I'm taking away
some we all know nobody can have ten
times our IQ well then why they
now do people make 10 times more than we
do a thousand times more than we do why
because they think and dream bigger than
we do high-performance people have high
expectations not average expectations
Matt and I were discussing some of the
things about why you've discounted a
subconscious level some of the things
that happened because absence of
evidence is not evidence of absence and
he said something very profound for an
Australian this is heavy duty but he
said I decided to do it even though it
was stupid I decided to do it stupid
meaning the follow the process to an
intellectually bright guy was an
engineer and so you won't you see you'll
figure out a better way and he followed
the stupid process that works and has
been working for 45 years 20-some years
before when I was doing it in 22 years
since I've been coaching and he called
it I wasn't trying to be insulting
everything it's just I just decided to
follow this you know how did you say
instead of trying to be frog I was just
trying to be stupid shut that part of my
brain and just do it
and what happens he did it and that's
why it's hard for the youtubers and all
the other because you can't dumb you
know dumb down you won't you will not
believe that it's easy you can't you
know you won't tease but he put it very
succinctly you know just dumb down and
shut off that part of his brain and just
follow the steps
you don't need case studies you have a
you have a template you have a script
that a monkey can read
that Alex wants a case study because he
wants to know this behind it because
he's stupid and that's why for your
donating him case studies how many times
do I have to say you had to script I
said don't change up smart on the script
not a comma if it's got mr. Morse ended
up misspelled the last thing you need is
a case study this is why you're poor
this is what a [ __ ] watching this on
youtube were so poor hi my name is Dan
Pena and I'm thanking every Carmichael
for the opportunities given me for this
cameo if you will most people know that
I'm a bad boy barrio bad boy that made
good who's now the Laird of Gus Picasso
that's pretty much a given now but when
I was starting out that wasn't and the
most of you know that I went to a school
University that I had to explain about
because it was in the famous University
and some of you may or may not know that
I flunked out a university three times
and then I was arrested five times for
alcohol-related mischief and some of the
mischief was very curious when I am from
the barrio of East Los Angeles in my
adolescent years and but I had a alpha
male role model dad and that was a
strict disciplinarian it was a veteran
of the Second World War and the Korean
War discipline focus and commitment are
the three bedrocks of all high
performance I'm also known as the 50
billion dollar man why am i known as a
50 billion dollar man because with kids
just like you I've created over fifty
billion dollars since 1993 in value and
equity one item that has really lost on
most people is all my products free I
give it all away for you why do I give
it all the way free because I want to
take a last excuse you kids might have
for not trying or forgiving us another
thing that's often not
recognized in addition to be giving all
my product away free is that 99.999%
above all the kids did it benefit from
purely in the last 24 years I've never
met I would know um if they came in and
slapped me in the face all my stuff to
create wealth is unlike sight free
through my podcast my newsletters etc
etc so use it free and I wish you all
the best of luck and to your quantum
leap in life and in business thank you
they decide to watch watching I mean
this pity because we on your feet two
three zero attitude so does the payment
on screwed events do more profound next
check out the link in the description
you can go and tap through both after
love to know which clips residents and
most of you what left me to take this
video and immediately apply to your life
or to business somehow leave it in the
comments below I'm really curious that's
what you have to say I also want to give
a quick chatter - Charles bottom Sancho
thank you so much your finger - probably
my folks here one word and making that
awesome review on your YouTube channel I
really appreciate this apartment and I'm
so glad to enjoy life going to be
reviewing his book Evan Carmichael thank
you guys so much for watching I believe
in you hope you teach to believe in
yourself
and whatever your one word is much loved
[Music]
high-performance is anything but easy
and stand on tops even harder than
getting to the top now I've been on the
top of my game arguably for three and a
half decades
I haven't had to work at 35 years people
ask me how do I get up in the morning I
get up fired up I'm fired up I've been
high on life since 1974 that I thought
about it and actually since I got out of
CS 50 years ago today what better is not
an option and I do fail but when I do
fail I am so oh I can't believe it and
let's be an error there was be a typo
because I'm so used to winning being a
high-performance person is not possible
for everybody you have a quote that says
that so and so going to your seminar and
you are not for everybody what kind of
person are you and is being a
high-performance person for what is that
suit okay well this we're talking about
by definition high performance not
somebody else's okay if you're willing
as if there's a hip-hop guys speaker I
can't even name now it's been on London
real the hip-hop creature ever whoever
it is he said if you don't want success
more than you want air the breed don't
come to me then oh you feel life yes
because if you've got the desire and you
wanted to make the sacrifices I've done
a four hundred million dollar deal with
a guy who dropped out of school at 14
who's had one old level you don't know
what that means but in European terms
that means he passed only one course
when he left school carpentry mm-hmm oh
you're one of the biggest pop star girls
and it gets different motivation gets
you going good habits keep it going
Jim Ryan the great miler who never won a
gold medal in the Olympics for the 1,500
meter told me about 40 years ago
then habits gets you could keep your
motivation starts you but good habits
but it's like you know it's like train
mean the if I didn't train as much as I
did I'm 70 years old I wouldn't look
like I look and I don't feel 70 people
tell me I don't look 70 and I can
normally work people a lot younger than
me into the ground but I've been doing
it for almost 50 years now yeah non-stop
she's negative non-stop